when I sit down with the people who  write out the contracts for the MBA and  for the NFL and for professional music  and for acting contracts we need to go  to the top lawyers the top execs the  owners of the stadiums the owners of the  football teams and the owners of the  record labels and we're going to put  them all in one room and we're going to  read every dot let's go top 10 in each  one of these categories right let's read  Michael B Jordan why would any of those  why would any of that bro hey hey bro I  ain't finished I ain't finished my  sentence  hey boy don't finish I told you  oh don't treat me like a boy then I'm  gonna finish my sentence or my idea  nothing you're saying has got anything  to do with the Tweet cool  so I was in the middle of a sentence boy